[Musique]
voilà décryptage avec vous à cinéastre
bonjour Wassim cette question qui est
sur toutes les lèvres aujourd'hui que va
devenir Wagner l'une des questions qui
est posée après cette offre faite hier
par Vladimir Poutine donc effectivement
après ma mort je pense qu'il faut qu'il
faut départager Wagner en Ukraine et sa
présence sont recrutement sa structure
en Russie et l'activité de Wagner sur
d'autres théâtres beaucoup plus
lointains il faut pas oublier que Wagner
est un outil très précieux construit au
fil des années et qui servent finalement
les intérêts politiques de la Russie et
qui a fait revenir la réussite sur sa
santé théâtre où elle était absente ça
il ne faut pas l'oublier donc ce n'est
pas un outil que la réussite ou Vladimir
Poutine va juste décider de gaspiller
comme ça donc ça c'est d'un côté d'un
autre côté il y a l'empire financier de
Wagner autour duquel tourne plusieurs
personnalités parce que il y a des
organisations ou des groupes parallèles
similaires à Wagner qui sont actifs
aujourd'hui et qui ont une existence
même si il faut rappeler que les groupes
paramilitaires ou les compagnies de
sécurité privée n'ont pas d'existence
légale en Russie donc l'existence même
de Wagner est une anomalie et on peut
imaginer que tous ces effectifs encore
une fois ils vont pas être gaspillés ils
vont être redirigés vers les zones de
conflits comme au Levant ou comme en
Afrique ce qui va servir de soupape on
va dire donc tous les mécontents au lieu
de les avoir en Ukraine ou en Russie ou
juste à côté en Biélorussie le mecs se
battre ailleurs sur des théâtres
lointains et ça c'est une politique et
une logique et une tactique qui a été
utilisée par tous les empires depuis les
empires existent on envoie des corps
expéditionnaires comme ça on minimise le
risque de révolte chez soi ce qui
arrangerait si on vous suit bien
finalement le Kremlin aujourd'hui ce qui
arrangerait le Kremlin est-ce qui
arrangerait aussi beaucoup de gens qui y
avait des yeux ou qui cherchaient à
prendre la place de prix d'origine et à
retirer les bénéfices financiers avant
tout de cette aventure qui s'appelle
Wagner il faut encore une fois rappeler
que Wagner revient plus de 10 ans quand
même ça te construction que du jour au
lendemain les Russes vont pas décider de
dire tiens on jette tout ça on jette le
bébé avec l'eau du bain genre
effectivement on voit mal Wagner
disparaître du jour au lendemain ou en
tout cas son essence quand on voit la
scie solide qu'elle a acquis au fil du
temps ça a commencé en Syrie ça a
commencé en Syrie ça s'appelait pas
vaguener on remonte à 2012 donc il y a
le slavon et Corse limited qui a
commencé son engagement en série dès
2012 donc en 2013 c'était devenu Wagner
et ça c'est une des premières images qui
est sorti depuis la série et on voyait
donc des paramilitaires russes présents
au sol en Syrie en soutien à l'armée
syrienne assainissement bien avant
l'arrivée des effectifs combattants
russes en série pour soutenir Bachar
el-Assad en 2015 et là on va voir aussi
on a des photos des premières exactions
en fait c'est des captures d'une vidéo
où on voit et on va aller on va aller
voir où on voit des des mercenaires
russes en tout cas
là c'est un des mercenaires russes on va
voir dans les photos qui suivent parce
qu'on a décidé de pas passer la vidéo
tel quel qui s'en prennent un déserteur
de l'armée syrienne donc même pas un
rebelle pas un djihadisme un désacteur
de la mer régulière c'est rien qui sera
tué à coup de massues à coup de marteau
et qui sera brûlé derrière et encore une
capture qu'on va voir et si on parle de
ça parce que beaucoup d'autres exactions
mais si on parle de ça parce que la
légende ou le symbole de la massue
utilisé par Wagner et la massue qui a
été envoyé ça a démarré ici là on va
voir la prochaine photo où on voit ce
même donc mercenaire russe utilisez une
massue voilà pour s'en prendre à ce
désacteur de l'armée syrienne donc ça ça
fait partie des premières des toutes
premières exactions documentées en série
et la légende de la massue a démarré ici
donc ça c'était la période syrienne ils
ont participé à des combats on a des une
carte pour montrer les les combats
particulièrement au combat on va dire
qu'ils se sont dé à un Palmy donc
Palmyre la ville historique tadmore en
arabe il y a eu quatre grandes batailles
donc la ville était prise par l'État
islamique reprise par le régime avec
l'aide des Russes puis reprise par
l'État islamique et ce qui est ce qui
est bon à savoir c'est que la dernière
bataille de Palmyre les Américains ont
participé au avec des frappes aériennes
donc on soutient à la bceen et à Wagner
sauf qu'en 2018 et on voit aussi sur la
carte et la bataille de racham ou les
mercenaires de Wagner avec d'autres
miliciens pro syriens ont essayé de
prendre un champ pétrolier qui était
entre les mains des factions Kurdes et
c'est là en 2018 que l'armée américaine
les a frappé très dur avec l'aviation il
y a eu des centaines de morts des
dizaines de Russes ont été tués et ça
n'a pas suscité la réaction de Moscou
parce qu'il faut rappeler que ce n'est
pas la mer régulière russe ce sont des
mercenaires et ça suit le principe ce
qu'on appelle de plus de building ça
veut dire pouvoir nier l'implication du
groupe si besoin et permettre à Moscou
de peut pas réagir comme dans ce cas de
figure où ils ont été frappé très dur
par les par les Américains d'ailleurs
Moscou n'a jamais admis la présence de
Wagner ou de compagnies paramilitaires
en série alors qu'elle a admise ailleurs
par exemple on m'a dit ou en Acer
deuxième territoire important qui a
marqué l'entrée de Wagner donc en
Afrique c'était le camp le conflit est
libyen où ils étaient du côté du
maréchal afta donc dans son combat
contre le gouvernement de Tripoli ils
ont été impliqués dans plusieurs
batailles et surtout la bataille pour la
prise de Tripoli et dernièrement
dernièrement en 2000 en 2019 donc
présence en Libye pas plus de 1000
combattants des snipers des artificiers
qui ont posé des bombes qui ont posé des
mines et pour aider le maréchal after
dans sa guerre contre les autres
factions à Tripoli et aussi pour
l'anecdote donc comme pour la dernière
bataille de Palmyre les Américains ont
soutenu par la frappe aérienne en série
du côté du maréchalaftal il y avait
aussi
euh les Français donc la France s'est
retrouvée pendant cette bataille de fait
du côté du maréchal after et donc de
fait du côté de Wagner qui aussi était
aidé en matériel par les Émirats arabes
unis en matériel lourd de guerre comme
missile solaire et équipement et
d'ailleurs ils sont toujours présents en
Libye avec de l'équipement fourni par
les alliés de la France et par les
humains merci beaucoup Wassim on
comprend bien au vu de ce petit rappel
historique ce groupe ne risque pas de
disparaître du jour du jour au lendemain
merci dans le